okay so this past saturday the world of
counter-strike woke up to the news that
fnatic's long-time rifler and
two-time major winner crims had been
vac banned now i know what you're
thinking
crims i thought flusho was the cheater
maybe jw but here's the thing
it seems our boy got clapped for doing
something
even crazier than cheating
he played the game using a third-party
scandinavian matchmaking service
okay so like i said it's saturday
morning i and the rest of north america
get out of bed grab a coffee sit down
throw flom on the second monitor
hop on twitter and see that a member of
fnatic's dynastic cs go roster
has been there excuse me
zack band but to get an advantage over
each other
they're using the gear the best part
it isn't senor vak it isn't even jay
dubs
it's freddy krimz johansen the stalwart
unassuming
support it's always the quiet ones you
know
i should be aware that there's an awp
still up crims yeah he's
he's really on the at what point is that
too much
so for all the non-cs players out there
what is
vac and why does everyone meme on it so
much
vac stands for valve anti-cheat the
super old utterly useless anti-cheat
that's worked
tirelessly to combat aim and wall hacks
in esport titles such as counter-strike
for nearly two decades
this right here is actual footage of vac
detecting cheats in cs go the thing is
since it's the only official anti-cheat
in cs
a ban issued by vac is like a religious
declaration
if you are a pro or an aspiring pro and
you're slapped with a vac ban
and it's determined to be legit you're
literally [ __ ]
from that moment on you are dead to
valve and by extension
everyone encounters right by valve's own
admission
vac bans are permanent non-negotiable
and cannot be removed by steam support
so if you're a regular dude like you and
me there's pretty much nothing you can
do
anyway after freaking out for like half
a second it became pretty apparent that
the ban
wasn't in any way related to cheating at
least
that's what crims tried to have everyone
believe so what was the cause if not
cheating
well as virtually every report came to
indicate it had to do with krimz's use
of something called
esportal so for any boys like me who
genuinely had no idea what esportle was
it's sort of like the scandinavian
equivalent of faceit or esea
and like all third-party web-based
competitive platforms for cs go
it has its own matchmaking system
tournament infrastructure
and anti-cheat that last one's what
caught vac's attention and got krimz's
10-year-old account banned
days before an official match now for
those who don't know a vac man is
different from an
overwatch band in that it's automated
valve has no control over
kind of like an alarm system so it saw
something about this third-party
anti-cheat that it didn't like and
triggered the ban as a result
unfortunately this isn't out of the
ordinary
vac like anything related to cs go's
engine
is legitimately ancient meaning that
it's old
curmudgeonly and doesn't work well with
others
kind of like devon
i'm
that's ironic of course since as
mentioned earlier it's
literally the worst anti-cheat known to
man
hey uh vac am i cool to use actual wall
hacks
oh yeah no no sure go crazy sweet uh
what about obs
nope suffice it to say fnatic's head
coach quickly released a statement
claiming that not only was krimz not a
dirty filthy cheater but that they'd
reached out to everyone involved
including valve to sort out the issue as
soon as possible quote
we have reached out to valve to's and
third-party community websites where
krimz has been competing to understand
the nature of this unexpected shutdown
of his account
we have no reason to believe that this
is the consequence of any intentional
usage of any illegal program
we are hopeful that this can be resolved
at the earliest to clear up all
speculations and solve the problem
s portal also claimed that they'd
reached out to valve and were hoping to
rectify the issue
but that they decided to shut down the
entire matchmaking service until
everything had been cleared up so as not
to get anyone else banned
because as it turns out a lot of other
users got banned as well
i don't know the exact number but it was
enough that they certainly made their
presence known
on social media of course the janitor
doesn't work on weekends
so it wasn't until late monday less than
24 hours before his match
that krimz's vacation came to an end the
question was what about the users who'd
suffered wrongful bans
and weren't two-time major winners would
valve make time for them
as it turns out yes later on monday
esportal sent out a mass
email informing everyone on their
platform that all accidental vac bans
had been removed
and that they'd quote established with
valve what had caused the issue and
released an update that would prevent it
from happening again now there were some
questions that were left unanswered
like what happens to those who allegedly
received game bans for using eastworld
but given how quickly valve reversed the
vac bans
there's likely no need to worry you also
can't help but wonder if something like
this could ever happen
with faceit or esea that's not to say
valve wouldn't rectify it if it did but
given how many false bands have been
dished out as of late and the fact that
inventories are literally worth more
than ever
you can't help but be a little nervous
about these things thankfully
this time around everything worked out
perfectly not only did krimz get to play
his match but
fortunately for all of esporto's other
users the high-profile nature of his ban
means that they got unbanned probably a
lot faster than they would have
otherwise
i have to say for as much as the
community loves to meme on valve for
being slow-footed when it comes to
fixing
literally anything in cs go they left
little to be desired in their handling
of the situation
props to you mr gaben sir now
for the real question where the [ __ ] is
the operation
i should have been an actor i did i did
theater for years
literally years i was actually a
competitive public speaker in high
school
that's like my dorky [ __ ] i was also
in band actually i don't know if that's
more dorky than being in band but
um band was sick dude
i'm playing tenor sax bruh nice i played
[Music]
baritone
[Music]
him